while inflation in the united states has
hit 9.1 percent there's plenty of other
places around the world that have way
higher inflation and people are
suffering let's take argentina as a
quintessential example it is estimated
that by the end of this year argentinian
citizens may be experiencing inflation
as high as 90 percent year over year
that 90 inflation means that their money
is getting cut in half in its purchasing
power on an annual basis this is
completely unsustainable for the south
american country which is not only a
massive part of the continent but also
houses tens of millions of citizens
as we begin to think about the people on
the ground in a 90 inflation environment
prices change day to day it's nearly
impossible to plan your life and all you
think about is how can you get out of
the currency so that you can buy some
goods buy store of value or somehow some
way protect the economic value that you
go to work for and that you worked so
hard for here's some quotes from the
bloomberg article argentines face the
prospect of 90 inflation by year end
after the economy ministers exit
triggered overnight price rises and the
central bank comes under pressure to let
the peso depreciate more rapidly that'd
be the fastest pace since hyperinflation
three decades ago and the highest rate
in the world outside of venezuela and
sudan according to forecast from the imf
the dramatic exit of former economy
minister martin guzman this month led to
price markups by many businesses some
argentines raced to the shops the
morning after guzman quit to try to
stock up ahead of peso devaluation and
price hikes now that 90 inflation number
is important it'll grab all the
headlines but there's another aspect of
the argentine economy that is important
to understand they have implemented
price controls on more than 1 000
different goods within their economy any
time that you see price controls being
implemented it means that politicians
central bankers and people in positions
of power and influence are starting to
intervene even more into the market they
claim that they're doing it for a good
reason that they want to stop price
gouging or that they want to help the
average citizen but what we know is that
the free market can solve problems much
faster than an intervention driven
monetary policy or solution and so
regardless of what politicians say price
controls are a bad bad decision and as
we watch in argentina there are price
controls on a lot of goods but inflation
remains out of control
all you're doing is you're putting more
stress on the system and you're not
actually solving the problem i have no
clue what the right solution is in
argentina it looks like inflation is on
a runaway path the people on the ground
are suffering
and not only do they understand
inflation really well because out of
necessity they've had to get a crash
course
when they walk into the grocery store or
they try and protect that purchasing
power but also there's pain that doesn't
show up in the economic data people lose
their life savings people lose their
businesses and literally people go
hungry because they can't afford the
skyrocketing cost of food whatever ends
up being the solution i hope it comes
fast because living in a high inflation
environment of 90 percent
is completely unsustainable for your
average family